hi I'm Nate Dern I'm the head of the
Comedy Central creators program and I'm
Brian I was going to introduce I was
gonna introduce the creators program is
putting five emerging comedians together
to create a topical show can bet
everything that's happening in pop
culture Monday through Thursday and
that's gonna be lots of screaming no
matter what the format ends up being and
we're also gonna make a workplace comedy
series we wake up you think of goo goo
stuff they film it was your first
impression of Brack yeah I thought he
was a dick I know that she thought I was
a dick when we first met each other and
so now my first impression has been I
should always be extra nice to Hannah
all right which one's cutest and which
one would you it's cool I like Jordan he
seems like a weirdo but I think he like
is more normal than what he wears I just
found this subreddit called watch people
die which is like just found footage of
a lot of people like of dying that's
horrible
yeah it's really bad my first impression
of Hannah is she deserves to be on Riya
Wow or if you're aware but Riya is a
very selective dating site that has
denied Hannah and I have taken on the
charge to make sure that she gets on
right yeah I need to be on Riya I'm a
very easy day like I will do you know
like it's all right on it
you're gonna hate this question what
comedians style would you say you're
similar to I don't know man I hate this
question whatever comedian hates this
question most it's probably who I
aligned with Nick Kroll is a huge
influence of mine so I like to do this
like hybrid character and stand-up thing
which he does so well I like American
celebrities they mostly food Kevin Bacon
Jacques Pham
Scarlett Johansson yeah Scarlett
Johansson the comic said they used to
compare me to was Cedric the Entertainer
and that's because they say I look like
him I can't argue with that they said if
we need to do a show together you could
be the dad when was the last time you
were embarrassed I don't get embarrassed
I get apologetic when's the last time
you apologized I think I've done it
several times while sitting here I think
you're at if I thought about every time
I got embarrassed I would never leave
Alice let's imagine when I got the news
I was picked to be a digital creator we
did it via FaceTime I was sitting there
I didn't know to do my face cuz it's
FaceTime you could also see your dumb
face in the top corner somehow see see
right here hi guys
thanks for answering those questions
Ryan I'm really looking forward to
working with you in 30 minutes when we
meet up again is that earnest enough for
you I got those sweet Internet I thought
that was nice
[Music]